just port you get started I do want to
say that there's going to be a lot of
French pronunciations in this one indeed
the character of this video is Joan of
Arc I'm going with the accepted English
pronunciation of her name if you wanna
have a go at me in the comments ya can
she's one of history's youngest warriors
at an age when most of us were stressing
out about what to wear to school Joan of
Arc was leading thousands of French
troops into battle against the English
supposedly inspired by divine visions of
Catholicism's greatest Saints Joan first
took up her sword at age 16 she was
leading armies by 17 and she was burned
at the stake before she was even 20 in a
short life she managed to change the
course of the Hundred Years War ending
English domination of France certainly
not bad for a literate girl from the
sticks but while most of us know the
name Joan of Arc and know her tragic
ends how much do we actually know about
her life well join us today as we take a
look at the simple peasant girl who
changed European history before dying
alone and disgraced convinced that she
was a failure
we don't know today the exact date of
Jones birth all we know is that it was
sometime in 1412 - a farming family of
some means now some means here is
definitely a relative term Jones village
of Domremy in northeastern France was
shockingly port still her father Jean
managed to scrape together 50 acres of
farm lands and the family lived in the
biggest house in the town for young joan
life in domine mince a life of sewing
and taking care of animals as a girl in
medieval Europe no one taught her to
read and write or to other manly things
they did teach her how to pray though
Joan's mother Isabelle Romney was a
devout Catholic and how devout was she
well there's evidence Isabelle may have
made a pilgrimage to Rome earlier in
life a crazy feat for a woman living at
a time when traveling three villages
over meant a day's riding and the
knowledge that you might be killed by
bandits but his vault lived in a time
when public devotion afforded a woman a
certain level of respect that was not
found elsewhere early 15th century
France was filled with female
visionaries who it was taken as fact
could communicate with God while
Isabelle herself never claimed to be a
mystic she likely told young Joan all
about these women still Joan's early
life was relatively uneventful she
became a master seamstress she worked on
her dad's farm she made a handful of
friends had she been born at a different
time it's doubtful we'd be talking about
her at all
heck it's doubtful those in Domremy
would have even remembered her but Joan
wasn't born at any time she was born in
1412 in northern France in northern
France in 1412 was a place in the grip
of a destructive conflict Joan of Arc
had been born slap-bang in the middle of
the Hundred Years War
[Music]
the Hundred Years War could win awards
for the least accurately named
historical events in fact it was a
series of wars between England and
France and it lasted 116 years not a
hundred now normally what would do is
we'd mention the Hundred Years War and
we'd just move on but Joan of Arc's life
was so short and so tied up in the
Hundred Years War that would have to
keep halting the narrative every two
seconds just to stop you from going
what's going on Simon
so like a fun Pixar short here is our
quick biography of the 100 Years War
that was not a hundred years and wasn't
really a single war so 1066 the Norman
King William the Conqueror earns his
nickname by conquering England crucially
he retained his claim on the French
throne as did his descendants nearly 300
years later in 1328 King Charles the
fourth of France he dies this was super
good news for Williams descendant Edward
the third who was next in line for the
throne so this point you probably think
well I good news Edward gets two
countries right well no instead the
French crowns local noble Philip the
sixth Oh while blowing raspberries
across the channel at England's fed up
with all of these Frenchie's taunting in
his general direction Edward went to war
with France in 1337 by 1360 everyone was
tired of warring and Edward accepted a
trunk of northern France in return for
abandoning his claims to the throne so
the warring it stops until thirteen
eighty when the French crowned crazy
Charles the sixth a guy who genuinely
believed that he was made of glass
Charles the sixth was so incapable of
ruling that he created a power vacuum in
1407 the French houses of all Aeon and
burgundy actually went to war to fill it
the House of Burgundy by the way that's
the name you're going to want to
remember so a year after Joan was born
in 1413 Henry v was crowned king of
England desperate to revive his claim to
the French throne
Henry demanded to marry one of Charles
the sixes daughters the French in
response that were pretty much like nah
that's not happenin and England's and
France they went to war yet again but
this time the House of Burgundy allied
with the English this led to the Treaty
of tois in 1420 when the English and
burgundy ins not only booted the French
up their backsides but made off
with their pantaloons to the treaty was
humiliating for France alongside other
stuff it said things up so Henry would
inherit the French throne when Charles
died but then Henry made the mistake of
dying just before Charles also died
technically making Henry's 10 month old
son Henry the sixth king of both nations
the French decided that being ruled by a
baby was just a bit ridiculous
so they made Charles of Valois King
instead and yes we return to that old
classic French play of screw the Treaty
and blow raspberries across the channel
only the English they were no longer
across the channel but they were
occupying the north of France then
included not only Paris but also rancer
City where Charles of Valois had to be
crowned to be recognized as king so
that's where things were by 1425 the
English and the Burgundian said
everything above the Loire River while
Charles of Valois stood to the South
unable to become King until he made it
to Ross it would take a miracle to break
this deadlock and ends this near century
of conflicts luckily though miracles
were Joan of Arc was all about
vistas Charles of Valois was sulking
around wishing he could be king young
Joan of Arc was having an extremely
spooky experience now aged 13 Joan's
life in Durham II was much the same as
it was when we last left her but there
was one major difference as she reached
puberty Jones started having visions of
some Catherine's and Margaret of Antioch
and some Michael
now first these visions they simply told
her to lead a pious life and remain a
virgin but as time passed they started
telling her you know actually how about
you become a warrior and he put Charles
of Valois on the throne that sounds
pretty good right now as I said earlier
female visionaries they weren't uncommon
in France but that doesn't mean that
people took them seriously the other
kids they certainly laughed at Joan's
visions but the visions they persisted
until one day in May of 1428 when Joan
was 16 the Saint suddenly told her to go
to see Charles in she know now this was
a bit of a problem the war had left
steadfastly Pro Charles Domremy
completely surrounded by hostile
burgundy and territory which in on
around 500 kilometers away any journey
Joan undertook on her own would likely
have ended up with her debt so Joan
didn't even try instead she went to the
nearby pro-child stronghold of Vancouver
there she found the garrison commander
Robert at Bari Corps and she demanded
that he send her to the rightful king
Robert Bao Recor responded by throwing
her out on her ear we're not joking here
he actually told Joan to make sure that
her father gave her a good beating
spurns Joan went back to Domremy
presumably muttering obscenities the
rest of 1428 it passed rather slowly in
Domremy Joan's father tried to marry her
off only for Joan to successfully argue
in court that should taken a vow of
chastity and must remain single
throughout the proceeds Joan kept on
talking about her visions to the point
that the news began to seep out to other
villagers there are even stirrings that
she might be the Virgin prophesized to
lead France to victory over England
eventually the rumors they reached the
Burgundian forces they responded by
sacking Joan's village now remember here
the house of Burgundy it was allied with
England the last thing they wanted was
some prophetess saying Charles of Valois
should be the king if the sacking was
meant to be a warning though it had the
opposite effect in January of 1429 Joan
returned to Van cooler that she rode
word of her visions spread by the time
she reached Robert Vadra core she was a
minor celebrity and Patrick or noticed
when drone repeated her demand to see
Charles Madrick or unexpectedly agreed
he gave Jones six armed men as an escort
and pointed her in the direction of
tional and just like that Joan of Arc
was off to see the king now II guess
you're probably wondering right now well
why did Baudricourt changes mind
something it was just to get this pushy
peasant off his back others think though
that had taken note of the burgundy and
sacking Jones village and realized there
must be something to her but there is a
more likely explanation by early 1429
the French they were desperate the news
of the war coming in could not be worse
the English in the burgundians were
running riot in the north while French
forces were bankrupt and low and morale
worse back in October of 1428 the
English had laid siege to the vital town
of ah Lian
word was only always about to fall when
it did the game it would be over for the
French all of this may be why on
February the 13th 1429 Joan and her
guard of six men were allowed to ride
out of Vancouver and into the unknown we
really can't stress just how dangerous
this was Joan was a girl riding into
lawless territory it doesn't take much
to imagine what certain men might have
done to her thankfully don't realized
this before setting off she cut her hair
short and began dressing in men's
clothes there's evidence that it was
more than just to disguise during her
ride to Shannon Joan adopted the habits
of the six men that she was with she
slept alongside them she dressed with
them she acted like one of the boys it's
something she'd do while serving in
Charles's army and it's likely the key
to the respect that and then had for her
eleven days after setting off Jonah nor
entourage they finally arrived at Shin
on the stories of what happened next
they're the stuff of legends Charles
refused to admit this strange girl for
two days before finally testing her by
hiding among his entourage and calling
for her the moment she entered the room
Joan who couldn't possibly have seen him
before
strode straight up to Charles and
declared that she'd been charged by God
to lift the siege on Ollie or and make
him King it was an impressive display
and one probably matched in the private
meeting that the two of them had
although we can't say for sure because
no records of this survived
what we can say is that Charles emerge
from the meeting ready to give Joan a
chance this was not only to go to on
Leon but also to put her case to the
church authorities the idea was to
convince them that God was really
working through her over the next three
weeks Joan fielded questions from a
barrage of theologians she answered with
remarkable frankness
when asked to prove her abilities she
told them to send her to Allianz so that
she could prove herself by lifting the
siege eventually the theologians must
have figured it was a worthy shot
because they told Charles to roll with
it in April of fourteen twenty nine
Charles agreed it's a move that could
have ended his crumbling regime I mean
imagine the propaganda fake Kings ends
deluded girl to die in battle but dying
it only on it didn't even cross Joan's
mind she knew that God was on her side
and she was about to prove it
[Music]
all the time Joan was trying to convince
Charles to send her to oli or her legend
was growing we know this because the
French army was so broke that Charles
was relying on volunteers but when he
put out a call that basically said hey
he was to go with this crazy girl and
died defending a random City thousands
of men they actually responded it was
the first sign of the almost mystical
loyalty that Joan was able to command on
April the 29th 1429 Joan and a new army
arrived at the siege of alia Joan was
riding atop a white horse sir Christian
banner held high with some quick
diversionary work they gained access to
the city expecting to be heralded
saviors instead they found a city on the
brink of collapse Oh Leo was at that
time under the control of a man
literally called the bastard of Ollie
all while the title referred to his
parentage it could have been used in our
modern sense the bastard he loathed Joan
he was gearing up to surrender and
didn't need some jumped-up peasant
telling him that God was gonna save them
he locked Joan out of meetings and
refused to give her any role it was a
move designed to get rid of her but it
was also a move that failed to recognize
one important point all of the new
troops from Shannon were loyal to Joan
and the rank and file of only are they
were already turning to her side on may
the 4th Joan was resting when she
suddenly had another vision telling her
to attack the English she grabbed her
sword and banner and raced out of the
city to the east just as the French were
beginning an assault on a fort the sight
of God seemingly coming to their side
rallied the French as Joan plunged into
the thick of the battle they began to
fight Hart the fort fell and the next
day another and another
by the time May the 7th dawned the
French had done the impossible that
broken the siege all that remained was
to make a last assault on the English
and all er would be saved in the early
hours Joan led her army into battle
again by now the English were aware of
the spooky girl who made the French
fight like lions when the archers saw
her raise a banner they took aim the
arrow hit Rowan in the shoulder piercing
six inches deep at knocked her flat and
left her in agony she was dragged from
the field for emergency surgery had got
just abandoned the French not even close
that afternoon despite suffering a
wounds that would leave most of us
curled up on the floor wailing for a mum
don't return to the battlefield the
sight of her banner rising once more in
the afternoon sunlight sent up a great
cheer from the French they routed the
English by maybe eight thing Glyn's
forces they were in full retreat Joan of
Arc had done exactly what should
promised to do and the siege volley or
it was over
if you need proof of the kind of power
Joan of Arc had over the people look no
further than what happens after the
siege of ah Lian where the English in
Fleiss the French forces went to chase
them only to be told by Joan in no
uncertain terms that it was a Sunday and
good Catholics they shouldn't fight on a
Sunday amazingly these rough men they
listen to the English they were allowed
to escape as they retreated it said that
Joan went and wept over their dead a
sign of respect that was not being
reciprocated at our trial not that there
was much time for Joan to weep though
she already had another task she needed
to get Charles to Ross the problem was
that ROMs wasn't like ollie on sitting
on the front lines it was deep into the
English territory she might as well be
trying to take him to London but James
she kept on pressing and Charles was
eventually like fine I'll go but you're
gonna have to clear a path for me first
and well that's exactly what Joan did
over the next few weeks her army stormed
up and down the Loire River liberating
towns so effective was she that the
English began to believe that she was
possessed by the devil
not that Joan was particularly satanic
she never personally fought instead
using her banner and bravery to inspire
her men she also absolutely forbid her
forces from looting or to rape any women
the only unusual part from a medieval
perspective was the way that she
insisted on dressing with and sleeping
alongside her men it's because of this
that modern historians have theorized
that she may have been gay or trans
finally on June the 8th Joan's forces
met the remnants of the English at the
Battle of patay to say Joan's army
mopped the floor with them would be a
disservice to mops
they absolutely pulverized them after
this Charles he couldn't ignore Joan any
longer when she came back and told him
to get his kingly Astaroth he absolutely
agreed as Joan and Charles wrote across
northern France town after town fell
without even putting up a resistance
they liberated Orser chalan tois toir
was the place where the French had had
to sign the humiliating treaty with
Henry v on July the 16th or alarm e
finally reached Ross the gates opened as
they approached the city of Kings had
fallen just two months ago the idea of
getting the French army to Ross was like
asking jar jar binks to single-handedly
fight his way inside death
private chambers nope and now here Joan
and Charles were triumphant the very
next day July the 17th 1429 Charles of
Valois was coronated Charles the seventh
of France Joan stood beside him during
the ceremony ins afterwards she knelt
and called him that King and that points
her visions they just stopped a mission
it was over and God apparently didn't
have any more plans for her but it seems
Joan had gotten a taste for battle as
Charles the seventh embarked on a
victory lap around his newly conquered
territories the maid of all er made a
fateful decision she decided to go to
Paris
[Music]
on August the twenty-eighth 1429 Charles
the seventh opens peace negotiations
with Burgundians he worked suddenly not
really so hot on their alliance with the
using English the news gave June the bad
feeling that any peace treaty might
block her taking action against Paris
this was a big deal as the French
capital it lay in the hands of the
English so Joan she went rogue on
September the 8th she led her army out
independently to attack Paris this was a
major mistake to continue our Star Wars
metaphor take in Paris in 4029 was like
trying to break into the Death Star
using an anchovy the walls of the city
there were nearly 30 feet high
still Joan she tried waving her banner
and demanding that Paris surrender
she got a cross boat through the length
of her trouble and was dragged from the
battlefield screaming at her men to
continue the assault
instead they retreated when word got
back to Charles about what Joan was up
to during his delicate negotiations he
cut her loose yep
Joan might have made him King that
Charles had no problem with stopping her
supplies of weapons and Men and then
basically ignoring her while he did
allow her to keep fighting it was
probably just to get that busy but Joan
riding around liberating the odd small
town was a Joan not whipping up
discontent in the army still it wasn't
until the spring of 1430 that it became
clear just how far Charles was
distancing himself from the girl who had
saved his regime during an attempt to
relive a siege on Compiegne on May the
23rd Joan was knocked from a horse
behind enemy lines
seeing no point in fighting on she
allowed herself to be captured by the
Burgundian forces everyone expected
Charles to quickly trade for her
everyone they expected wrong Charles
just didn't lift a finger
this left the burgundians in an awkward
position on the one hands they wanted to
keep Charles happy and sign a treaty
with him but on the other hands they
didn't want citrus to return his best
leader to the field to take more
burgundy in towns so in July of 1430
they reached a compromise they sold Joan
to the English when Joan heard the news
she attempted to commit suicide by
leaping from the Tower of Castle but she
survived and on January the 3rd 1431 she
was handed over to English loyalists in
northern France so what did the English
and their Stooges do when they got their
grubby little paws on the girl he made
Charles the seventh King well they took
her to raw and they put her on trial
[Music]
[Applause]
on March the 25th 1431 the church
authorities at Rouen charged Joan on 70
religious points ranging from heresy to
dressing in men's clothes wears as that
last one seems it was legit Deuteronomy
chapter 22 verse 5 does actually contain
a direct prohibition from God on women
wearing men's clothes so well now you
know
Jones prosecutors they set theological
traps trying to trip her up in Doctrine
one of the key parts of the Joan of Arc
myth is that she was able to avoid these
traps and leave the prosecutors with
almost nothing those original 70 charges
the authorities were forced to throw 58
of them out but let's not kid ourselves
that this was just a spirited debate
about theology from the moment she got
to Ramon Joan was kept in awful
conditions she was chained to a filthy
bed in a filthy prison and given just
enough food to keep her from dying day
and night male guards they watched her
taunting her and threatened her with
assault on April the 18th Joan's
conditions they cost a default badly
sick convinced she was dying she begged
to be allowed to see a priest her
request
it was refused finally on May the 24th
the authorities that had enough unable
to settle the last 12 points they
dragged Joan outside for a mock
execution and then basically said sign
this confessional that execution next
time it's gonna be real Joan signed the
documents contained a very specific
Clause forbidding her from ever dressing
as a man again and a pain of death
something that this clause was inserted
very deliberately because a couple of
days later the authorities came to visit
Joan in prison and found her dressed as
a boy the official version is that Joan
did claimed the Saints had ordered her
to wear the clothes but other sources
suggest the cause was far darker
supposedly the men guarding Joan
stripped her naked and gave her the
choice of either putting on male clothes
or remaining naked before them knowing
what would happen if she remains naked
Joan she chose the clothes regardless
the outcome was the same on May the 30th
1431 Joan was led out to plaster view
Martians tied to a stake it said that
one of her guards slipped her a wooden
crucifix on the way in order to comfort
at that warm spring day Joan of Arc was
burned alive the executioner was
forbidden from easing her misery by
killing her before the flames reached
her flesh and Joan died screaming in
agony I reported last words were the
pitiful wailing
begging for some Michael to rescue her
the angel never appeared when the
execution was over the authorities had
her remains burnt again and then
scattered her ashes in the river the
story of Joan of Arc it was over or was
it 19 years after Joan was executed
Charles the seventh Road in Rouen by now
the Hundred Years War was winding down
and the French were on the verge of
winning stood in the city where his
one-time Savior burnt death
Charles ordered an inquiry into Joan's
trial this inquiry ended up at the
Vatican where in 1456 Pope Callixtus the
third annulled all charges against her
when the news reached France Joan was
elevated to a martyr the 116 years of
conflict had finally ended in 1493
and war shattered France was in need of
a national hero bended Joan they found
one she's kind of remained there ever
since on May the 16th 1920 Pope Benedict
the 15th canonized her four days later
the French Parliament declared a
national day in her honor fast forward
to today and she's arguably more famous
than Charles the 7th Henry the fifth or
any of the forgotten Kings who fought
and raged around her but there's more to
Droughns legacy than just being
remembered you can still see the effect
that she had on the entire world
historians think it's unlikely that
Charles the seventh would have 100 years
war without June that means an English
victory which as great as that sounds
would have meant no United French nation
just think no France don't know French
Revolution which means no de Polian
which essentially means no modern world
just to pick at random there would be no
metric system no Louisiana Purchase no
France to mock the Americans in the
Revolutionary Wars the entire planet
eerie look completely different whilst
Joan of Arc divinely inspired or just a
deluded peasant girl whose belief was
enough to make her a warrior it really
doesn't matter in her short 19 years on
earth Joan of Arc changed the world in
ways that even kings and emperors rarely
do she meant been born and nobody but
she died Joan of Arc the heroine of
France so I really hope you found the
video interesting if you did please do
give us a thumbs up below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this several times a
week also hit that notification bell so
you actually find out where we put our
new videos that's just the way the
YouTube works these days and as always
see you next time
[Music]